the jurogan experience
definitely before four i gotta go over
my notes and [ __ ]
kelly i'm so excited to see you guys i'm
like
it's this other stuff is just extra you
know like
i was ready to just hang out and come to
your show tonight
because i haven't seen you perform in
like
at least over a year year and a half at
the store was that the last time
yeah i don't miss that place uh so what
what's happening with it nothing they
got they can't even have a
outside bar anymore really because
they had like an outside bar and
everything they shut that down that
would have been perfect
they had the outside bar going on for a
while and then they they wouldn't let
them do outside
shows like there's just so much horse
[ __ ]
that's such a bummer because they
actually could have had small shows what
do you got there what is that
that's capo what is capo
jamie you want to take this one um it
changes the base notes of the guitar
the bass notes so well it changes all
the it basically like
raises you can raise the key
you can't like did not raise the key so
the sound from the microphone is
registering
on that that bar no
well how is it what it's for but her
sound from her
mic the sound from her guitar is
registering on the microphone
she was doing that for tuning yeah
that's what i'm asking yeah sorry
that capo on the neck is what we're
talking about no that's something we're
talking about you were talking about
this we're talking about the app
oh yeah it was a tuner yeah how does it
work
so it's registering it's seeing them
it's hearing the sound from the
microphone and it's registering on that
yeah that meter yeah and it's showing
you exactly where
each string should be is that what it is
oh yeah you know i just saw this new app
so that's not a capo no i would've got
looking for the capo
app i'm looking for a cable what are you
talking about there's this new thing my
friend told me that it's called decibel
meter
and it measures the frequencies whether
or not you're gonna go
deaf like last night's show yeah but i
this is where i want to like
like if i had the no if if i had
the wherewithal to have brought this out
when i was visited by
aliens the other day and realized like
you're a negative number
frequency is that i'm not like i could
have actually seen my phone just for
real
that's what it's doing it's tuning it to
the exact frequency
okay oh interesting so each string
has a very specific frequency
and a lot of times people just do it by
ear right you just kind of know
no i wouldn't say a lot of times if you
have perfect pitch
my my friend has perfect pitch he's like
i can tell you
i can't tell you the name of the of the
note
but i could tell you if it's sharp or
flat and when it's perfect and he does
it's crazy
it's so crazy is that just a rare
ability i think you can well they say
we're all born with perfect pitch they
say all babies are born with perfect
pitch and it's just something you lose
apparently but i think sometimes it's
just naturally there
and then other times you can like
cultivate it
fox notably has perfect pitch i believe
that's why you can recreate people's
voices so well i believe that that makes
sense
i feel like my pitch has been changing
since i haven't been singing that much
but we'll see
but i okay so yeah this tune is like
i haven't really written anything like
this and it's um
[Music]
yeah it's kind of like has to do with
everything we've been talking about
just like a summary pretty much
okay all right it's called save for love
[Music]
let that pipe make it burn
red make it hiss like the storm that's
hit your window
[Music]
fill up those lungs honey it won't be
long before the moment's gone in you're
dealing
with your sorrow
take what you can get count
all of your blessings cause that
hurricane ahead
might be never ending
[Music]
no one's gonna sleep through this one
there ain't no shelter
ain't no walls it's gonna hold it all
together safe for love
[Music]
oh
[Music]
then those busted bridges hold yourself
accountable give that soul
deep within you a voice like a parable
and make room for the hateful
see don't match your table give them
bread
for their broken hearts and kindness if
you're able
cause it's raining in hell
i know
no one's gonna sleep through this one
there ain't no shelter
ain't no walls it's gonna hold it all
together safe for love
[Music]
when there's [ __ ] to carry don't be
angry that it's heavy honey no
you're not alone there's arms here
at the ready to help you bear the load
no it ain't a one-way road we gotta do
this thing
together and grow
cause it's raining in hell
no one's gonna sleep through this one
there ain't no shelter
ain't no walls that's gonna hold it all
together safely
[Music]
save for life
[Music]
it's beautiful
thanks man
it's probably one of the
truer hippie ones i've written but i'm
it's like
it took me a minute catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience